a celebrated chef with three Chicago
restaurants Stephanie Izar gives a lot
of credit to mom and dad born in Chicago
she grew up in Connecticut where her
mother prepared dishes from around the
world and even posted menus on the
refrigerator which helped her friends
decide when to come over for dinner
smart friend after college it was
Stephanie's father who suggested
culinary school she went on to open her
acclaimed Chicago restaurant girl and
the goat which earned her a James Beard
Award and best new chef honor from food
and wine now she's added to her
restaurant realm with little goat diner
and her newest the asian-inspired
duck-duck goat which is one of my
favorite names you brought some here
some some of these dishes or dishes you
literally grew up with it's true yeah we
have over there we have some green beans
that you're cooking a wok with a
fermented black bean vinaigrette
we've got moo shu pork which I grew up
eating it's my mom's mandarin pancake
recipe nice scallion pancakes up front
which is a cool process it's almost
almost like an Asian croissant of sorts
and then some gooey char siew ribs Oh
shiny smells coming out which is amazing
I feel like I'm in the restaurant right
so your mom has a moo shu pork recipe
you she's obviously a she's a culinary
mind talked about growing up with a mom
it's amazing I think chefs either have a
mom that couldn't cook so they had had
to cook I was fortunate to have a mom
that cooked food from all over the world
I mean she had her friend come over once
every couple of months and they would
make the mandarin pancakes cuz it's
quite a process did you roll it out of a
couple of times I think they you know
enjoyed some cocktails while they were
doing which is what made it so fun but
then we would make them issue pork with
her we were you know taking the the lily
buds and pulling them in half tearing
off the mushrooms just kind of learning
cooking through my mom Wow but you
started going to business school correct
I did well I tried to you're at
University of Michigan I had a little
too much fun going to football games
instead so didn't get in the business
school and you know just never found
anything that I truly loved as far as
going to class you know I was not
feeling inspired but your first
restaurant job was actually Olive Garden
I read it was it was it's a great place
to learn I think it made me gave me a
glimpse into the rest
world that everybody's fun and you know
just a little bit crazy ago but very
passionate about what they do no matter
what restaurant they're at so it was a
good first step meaning for people who
don't know the story behind the goat
name in your restaurant titles what what
is that what is that about my last name
we say eyes are white in French it's
hard which is a mountain goat in the
Pyrenees Mountains it's actually a goat
antelope yeah but we were like
girl-on-the-go to lope doesn't really
have the ring to it and once we did
girl-on-the-go we thought well we should
probably serve goat so now we get eight
to ten holdouts a week a girl and they
go and serve all the different points
and really trying to inspire people to
try go about they're a big market for
good are people into it people are
getting into it there's a couple there's
some empanadas that are a really nice
introductory for people but then you can
have like the neck or the belly or
something a little more if you're
feeling more adventurous you you open
your first restaurant 2004 how did
winning Top Chef change things for you
it just gives you all these doors that
you can either all these opportunities
and you can kind of choose which path
you want to go on and puts you in front
of the whole country because Top Chef
has been so popular over the years we
love seeing female chefs in you are a
rare breed though do you think that the
landscape is changing I think there's
some amazing women emerging and I was
just I'm going to see misty Robbins
um this weekend while I'm in New York
one of my favorite female chefs I think
we're proving that um you know a few
more chefs can hold their own so it's
good very proud as you should be chef as
I ask you to sign this dish as we do on
the program I'll ask you the question we
always ask which is if you could share
this Chinese banquet with any person
past or present who would it be
I'm gonna have to say Ernie Banks mr.
cutter
because my son Ernie was named after any
banks and as well as our dog Bert Wow
who would be around to eat all the
scraps in the Florida but he from what I
know of him was an amazing person just
kind and you know not only great on the
baseball field but just in life and
that's what I you know when our son to
be well after the Cubs list it's
appropriate or any good Chicago right
there for you yes
Stephanie eyes are thank you and for
more on Stephanie eyes art and the dish
to our website at CBS this morning calm